Honduras is one of the poorest countries
in Central and South America but there's
a new idea about to be tried in Honduras
it's called as ed a privately run zone
with legal economic and political
autonomy the laws are all in place
investors are lined up and ready to go
and the big questions about to be
answered will this actually work this is
not a model city this is not best
practices this is an R and E ax the
Zed's face their fair share of this sort
of criticism early on when their biggest
proponent economist Paul Romer branded
them charter cities we need to allow for
the potential for partnerships between
nations
some critics even worried that roamers
ideas amounted to nothing more than
repackaged colonialism cases where
nations work together in effect de-facto
the way China and Britain worked
together to build first a little on Cape
Clive of the market model and then scale
it throughout China roamers idea to
partner with host nations proved
controversial and unconstitutional Romer
left the project and the Honduran
Congress revised the law so that the
Zed's would be run by private entities
instead of foreign governments we have a
reputation of being a very corrupt
country today it's not so much
ideological opposition to capitalism or
abstract concerns about colonialism that
makes most under and skeptical it's
something much more ingrained and
fundamental to Honduran society a
distrust of their own national
government they have this suspicion of
not knowing if they're making these
decisions because they actually think
it's the best thing for Honduras or is
there some other kind of interest behind
Claudia Maria Castro via his professor
of law in San Pedro Sula and says the
details of the plan remained murky and
raised more questions than answers for
her what will be my rights as
Kandra citizens will I be allowed inside
the zones perhaps it's an easier way to
get hands on our natural resources for
example students in vias class also feel
like they just don't know enough about
the plan to give their full support it's
just that we don't trust the politicians
who's gonna be ruling about the
government because if it's a government
it's a failure system it have many many
questions in there like many doubts I
think it's good to be positive but do
you also have to be realized
maybe it's not that we don't believe in
this projects just said we think it's
gonna happen and it's gonna fail because
of the same thing that all the other
projects have failed before you have to
remember that when we began the
discussion on these songs we had just
began to to come out of a political
crisis the political crisis of 2009 this
whole effort is about moving away from
trusting individuals and creating the
institutions that can be trusted by it
by digital public the problems that
exist are actually the reason why the za
is necessary it's the instrument that
can attract the levels of investment and
create the number of jobs that Honduras
needs to escape from poverty mark
Klugman a board member on the committee
responsible for green lighting of the
zones says the project may need time to
prove itself to Hondurans but the
governance in the zones will be the kind
that has proven itself over and over in
other parts of the world he calls the
idea institutional leapfrogging
institutional leapfrogging is to draw
upon what actually exists and is proven
usually it's things that are very old
it's things that are very familiar
there's a reason why the Honduran design
speaks of anglo-saxon common law because
it's essentially internationally it's
the standard but even some people
rooting for the success of the Honduran
SEDs
have reservations about Klugman x'
approach there are aspects of the
Honduran reform that don't mirror
certain essences of the start up cities
the start up city's idea one of the
essence of start of thinking of course
is that you need
multiple multiple different approaches
to the same problem so that one will
stick all of our eggs cannot be in
Honduras s basket startup cities Mahon
Honduran Zed's Krugman's leap stones
charter cities are various technologies
I want a more diverse conversation about
these technologies technologies so we
can find the best path forward for
billions of human beings to say that
this project should be focused on things
that are experimental no sir the
problems are pretty clear you have a
country where every year 75,000 people
essentially risk their lives in many
cases go into debt with very dangerous
criminal organizations that will try and
smuggle them into the US a lot of them
get on a train called la bestia and have
to hold on to these rails on the train
they're writing outside the Train they
have to hold on for hours and as happens
they get tired and if they let go or
they slip a lot of them will slip under
the train and will lose an arm or a leg
I mean that's a reality when you have so
many people living in a precarious
condition with such limited options that
the bestia the beast is their best
alternative right now my response to
people say listen I've got a really
clever idea and I would love a place to
try it out and you guys I don't know how
you've done if you've gotten this thing
done would you please try out my cool
and groovy idea what would you say to
them so I love your cool and groovy idea
that's that's really not on our to-do
list right now will the zetz fall
victims to cronyism and business as
usual as its critics fear or will they
out-compete the nation-state as the
world's primary form of government and
alleviate global poverty on a scale
never before seen as its most ardent
champions insist only time will tell
but as the project inches closer to
reality in the coming months we turn to
actual investors with money on the line
to see what they envision for the future
of Honduras and it sets
you